so fat gums skinny form finally made its
debut in the anime and today we're gonna
use information from both the vigilantes
manga and from the main show to explain
just how powerful it actually is but
before we begin this channel is so close
to a thousand subscribers so I would
really appreciate it if you would
subscribe okay let's get into it so in
order to explain the sheer force of fat
gums muscle form
let's first explain his regular quote to
give you a bit of context his base quark
is called fat absorption and it enables
his body fat to stick to anything it
comes into contact with and if he has
enough mass he can literally store large
objects and even people inside of his
body fat what that means in practice is
as we saw in previous episodes in season
four he can effectively restrain
villains simply by grabbing them and
then storing them inside his body which
is a bit intimate but you know however
it's worth noting that the size of fat
gums form depends on how much he eats
which is probably the best excuse in the
world to just binge eat his level of
obesity is literally saving people's
lives anyway fat gums quark is the
ultimate shield and is even more
resilient than Kirishima some breakable
form at least for the time being his fat
makes him essentially stab-proof
bulletproof explosion-proof although
evidently not punch proof as rapper was
still able to mess him up pretty good
let's move on to why you probably
clicked on this video how strong is his
skinny form if we're being literal here
fat gums actual skinny form is not that
much stronger than the average man
however I should probably be more
specific
while fat gums skinny form itself isn't
exceptionally strong we've seen at least
two occasions in the manga that the
process to turn into his skinny form is
where the real power lies his fat
absorbs the kinetic energy and he's able
to store as much of it as he wants
before releasing it in an ultimate
attack in the vigilantes spin-off manga
fad gum intentionally jumped on top of a
robot that was about to self-destruct
absorbing the full force of the
explosion inside his fat he then
released it in a relatively controlled
explosion and I say relatively because
the strength of the explosion was so
much that he admitted he could have
actually died if he didn't release it at
that moment but putting that aside if it
was a more reasonable explosion that
wasn't so big he would have been able to
control that energy and then release it
in a single
explosion like punch sort of like buck
who goes AP shot and remember guys fat
is literally stored energy the reason
our bodies make fat is to store energy
for later when we might not have access
to food so the way this quirk works
totally makes sense and because the
energy is stored in his fat the downside
of releasing it is that he immediately
transitions into his skinny form we saw
this in the main series when he absorbed
all of rappers powerful punches and
counter-attacked with a single punch
that was equivalent to all the punches
rapper had given him previously which
when you think about it is pretty
incredible that actually anyone survived
that so in short fat gums slim form has
no particular benefit but it's the
process of releasing his stored energy
that enables him to make a deadly attack
which then results in him becoming
skinny again and as a side note there
are a few other cool interesting things
about this character for example the
artist for the spin-off manga said that
fat combs design is one of her akashi's
personal favorites and his appearance is
designed to pay homage to a Matroska
doll yeah I'm hoping I said that right
matroska dolls come in varying sizes and
in designed to fit inside each other
this has strong parallels with fat gum
as his fat outer shell is essentially a
practical tool that he uses to fight
crime with his true muscley and skinny
form being underneath and according to
the latest ultra analysis book fat gum
has really impressive stats if you look
at his power he has a 5 out of 6 for
comparison the number two hero Hawks has
a 3 out of 6 and as far as I could see
Endeavor an oh my were the only heroes
who had a power level that was higher
than fat gums although admittedly I
didn't actually look that long but yeah
the guy's pretty pretty powerful like
you wouldn't imagine how powerful he is
just by looking at him I do like his
power because it's very versatile the
fact that you can be the ultimate shield
and then when needed you can turn
yourself into a spear that gives a level
of peace of mind that if you were stuck
in a situation by yourself you'd be able
to get out of it but that's gonna do it
for me today guys I have a longer video
plan next week where I'm gonna break
down my theory regarding how the
mysterious second user of one for all is
actually back ago and I posted that
theory on Twitter and everyone just went
crazy
I even got quite a few big youtubers
talking about it so I figured why not
make it into a video so until then
subscribe to the channel and make sure
you check out my video that explains the
limits of Kirishima unbreakable form
catch you next time peace